llegamos a la casa
de una manera muy particular siempre
dejando saber que estaba presente su
olor característico tu saludo
característico desde niño me di cuenta
lo importante que era ser inteligente
y lo responsable que uno debería
sentirse al nunca pasar desapercibido
desde niño que había si desde niño
así es lo que querías de una u otra
forma
inyectando mucho respeto y mucha mucha
credibilidad en cada una de tus palabras
crecí viviendo te creas
entendiendo lo que es un buen ejemplo un
ejemplo que nunca lo considere si no lo
considero pulcro ni perfecto sino un
ejemplo simplemente un ejemplo
crecí escuchando te crecí preguntándote
o simplemente
sorprendiéndome cuando te dabas cuenta
que algo me estaba pasando
llegabas a mí me decías simplemente lo
que pensabas y te ibas
gracias
educado desde la reflexión nunca desde
la imposición
recuerdo una vez una vez de niño tenía
yo cuatro o cinco años y tú llegaste a
la oficina del trabajo y yo estaba
matando bachacos en la entrada de la
casa
los estaba pisando esto está más cerca
de ti me dijiste
cuando puedas hacer los nuevos
los pizzas mientras tanto no
y sé que estoy caminando entre hasta la
casa no me dijiste más nada no me
regalaste simplemente me dejaste
pensando
tenía cuatro años algo así a los dos
años me cuentas ya yo estando grande
que llegaste a través de trabajo y me
viste discutiendo con mi hermano y con
amigos de él porque ellos querían matar
una araña que estaba en la esquina de la
entrada de la casa la querían tumbar y
yo les estaba discutiendo estaba
peleando estaba diciéndoles que hasta
que no la pudieran hacer nueva
no la podían quitar
no la quitaron la araña duro ahí hasta
que nos mudamos y así eras tú así eres
tú
un hombre reflexivo un hombre pensador
un hombre
que cuestionaba
todo lo que veía todo lo que escuchaba
con el fin de aportar algo y así me
educaste así me guste así cree así
pasaron los años y yo me fui olvidando
un poco más rebelde me fui volviendo más
más extrovertido
me fuiste viendo me fuiste observando
me fuiste educando me fuiste empujando
siempre hacia la reflexión
y es algo que agradezco
y agradecer a toda la vida
siempre estuviste ahí siempre
sin ser ese papá que gritaba a los
cuatro vientos lo orgulloso que estaba a
su hijo siempre estuviste ahí yo jugaba
fútbol y si estaba en pleno partido con
10 años 11 años qué sé yo y silbaba si
yo voy te va la grada ya estaba ahí
simplemente viendo simplemente
observando
cuando hacía las cosas muy bien nunca me
de subic hazte de la tierra nunca me ml
basta
simplemente
me decías ok
así con el arte
siempre estuviste ahí así con el rap
siempre estuviste ahí recuerdo mi
graduación llegaste solo te sentaste
solo y viste cuando me gradué del
colegio del bachillerato
recuerdo
año 2006 puede ser cuando lanzamos el
primer disco de rap de un grupo en el
que estuvo que ya no existen porque
siempre se va a llamar sistema
y en ese toque en esa muestra del disco
estuviste yo y sentado solo en la barra
del local simplemente viendo además una
de las canciones inicia con tu voz el
medio es tu voz y culmina con tu voz
fuiste
un gran rapero para mí y para todos
nosotros definitivamente y después en el
arte estaba exponiendo mi primera
exposición individual y llegaste
llegaste y con toda la gente que había
porque había mucha mucha mucha gente tú
estabas atrás sin jamás buscar
protagonismo pero siempre diciendo
presente nunca pasaste desapercibido
jamás pasaste desapercibido fuiste
fuiste eres serás un hombre muy muy muy
muy original muy original una
originalidad que creo que todo ser
humano consciente debería de conseguir a
lo largo de su vida
me ayudaste me ayudaste a entender
muchas cosas
me ayudó hasta a respetar el silencio me
ayudaste a entender lo importante que es
una pregunta lo importante que es no
tener miedo a preguntar que debo hacer
cómo puedo afrontar
alguna situación
sea cual sea alegría tristeza
cuál es cuál sea cuál cual cualquiera
y así fuimos
desde que dejamos de vivir juntos desde
que yo tenía 18 años y cada quien cogido
por su lado
nos veíamos cuando queríamos no teníamos
una rutina para vernos no éramos nos
fuimos nunca acs ese padre y ese dijo
que todos los domingos tienen que
sentarse a comer o que en la semana
tendrían que verse para tomar un café o
simplemente servir juntos o lo que sea
no basta un mensaje basta una llamada
cuando nos provoca se siempre nos
respetamos los espacios
nunca fuiste de ir a los cumpleaños
nunca fuiste de ir a celebrar el 24 de
diciembre hoy 31 de diciembre no eras
demasiado orgulloso del día del padre
siempre estuviste ahí ella
pero
el 24 de diciembre me insistía
insististe para verte para verte para ir
a verte y yo no quería no me sentía bien
todo ese año 2017 hablé contigo cosas
que me removían el alma que me partían
en 20
la mesa que habla contigo
fue para decirte cómo me sentía y la
ayuda que necesitaba de ti
y siempre respondiste una manera muy muy
muy muy profunda y desde el corazón y me
ayudaste me ayuda a saber muchas cosas
es el 24 de diciembre yo está triste lo
que sea estaba solo con mi perro con
lucas
luego de estar de haber conseguido un
sitio idóneo para pasar esa fecha tan
importante
me empujaron la vida me empujó tu
llamada me empujaba a ir a verte y fui a
verte
y pasé esa noche a tu lado hasta que tú
te fuiste y llamas ya mi casa
hablamos de arte ese día me dejaste
saber
lo importante que era para ti y saber
que yo me estaba realizando como artista
cosa que tú siempre fuiste un excelente
escultor un excelente pintor un artista
en
todo su esplendor
y me decía guau más allá que ya había
estado antes en algunas exposiciones
mías esta noche entendiste lo importante
que era para mí el arte iloílo y lo
fuerte que estaba haciendo en mi vida y
me dijiste claramente
mira ahora yo soy el papá de donaldo
barros cuando siempre tú has sido el
hijo donald o barros porque yo palabras
tuyas yo te amo desde que tú naciste
pero tú me has amado toda tu vida
y me dijiste también como abogado que
eres fuiste y serás lo que se hereda no
se hurta y tenía toda la razón toda la
razón porque heredé toda la sensibilidad
de ti mi manera de sacudir me la nariz
mi manera de sentarme mi manera de
caminar el desparpajo que tengo al
momento de hablar
sin nunca rallar en en la exageración ni
en la búsqueda de atención esa noche nos
vimos y fue una noche muy muy especial
al día siguiente fuiste a mi casa
a ver mis obras en mi casa
te sentaste en mi mueble
bis también mi casa con orgullo porque
ya por fin desde hace rato estaba ya
contento por la casa que tenía pero
estabas entendiendo que tenía mi hogar
y esta fiesta
y no está de más
a los meses
y hoy está entendiendo que uno va
creciendo y que las despedidas son
naturales
y a los meses me llaman y me dicen
se fue
yo estaba paseando al perro
entre la casa
y di la noticia
se fue
mi papá murió
murió solo en su casa
yo lo había sentido
lo había
asimilado ipsofacto mente / me dio un
baño me dio una ducha y fui a verte
llegue a tu casa llegué a tu casa
y antes de entrar a tu cuarto donde
estabas pregunté si eras tú
y me dijeron que sí que efectivamente
eras tú
cuando entré al cuarto y te vi ahí
sin vida
entendí perfectamente lo que había
pasado
y una vez más me dije a mí mismo este
hombre tiene una manera muy particular
de educarme porque no sentí
no sentí dolor sentir reflexión
y cuando te vi ahí
de mira
qué hiciste qué pasó
dale tranquilo
dale tranquilo vete tranquilo y estaba
ahí en tu cama
sin vida
diciéndome
que no habías muerto sino que habías
vivido y eso fue lo que entendí al
momento de haberte
sin vida te sentí vivo
porque entendí que no habías muerto sino
que habías vivido
te gradúas te de haber vivido por que
viviste como te dio la gana
fuiste un hombre libre fuiste un hombre
irreverente fuiste un hombre que jamás
pasó desapercibido que siempre estuviste
presente en todas mis conversaciones
siempre yo cada vez que podía hablar de
ti siempre siempre siempre lo sigo
haciendo y lo seguiré haciendo porque
eres un educador brutal eres un eres una
enseñanza infinita perpetua para toda la
vida
y entendí entendí la muerte gracias a ti
me enseñaste todo a este significado de
la muerte y en ese momento celebré
que hubieses vivido
y qué
que tenías que ir en cualquier momento y
te fuiste simplemente te fuiste fue
doloroso
fue doloroso fue fue difícil pero fue
necesario era tu manera de educarme
desde la reflexión
me obligaste de un golpe en la cara a
entender lo importante que es saber
vivir para entender la naturaleza de la
muerte y tú supiste vivir
y por eso más allá de sufrir tu partida
a la celebro celebró
que hayas vivido
y que así te haya apagado
si yo tuviese la oportunidad
de traerte de vuelta
no la tomaría
si tuviese la oportunidad
de ir atrás y cambiar algo no lo haría
porque viviste lo que tenías que vivir
me enseñaste lo que me tenía que enseñar
y me enseñas todavía lo que me tienes
que enseñar no cambiaría absolutamente
nada
normalmente nos apegamos luego de sentir
que nos falta algo que ahora no estás
para mí
simplemente no estás en mi proceso tiene
que ser mi proceso
calidad decírtelo
quería aprovechar la oportunidad
de que el mundo entero su pieza de ti
por qué
como dijiste aquella noche lo que se
hereda no se hurta
y me enseñaste me enseñas y me enseñará
a vivir a tomar mis oportunidades de la
mejor manera posible a entender y a
practicar que el respeto no sea negocio
que uno es verdaderamente libre cuando
respeta los límites de los demás que no
tiene que ser fiel a lo que nos dice el
corazón siempre mi nombre donaldo barros
es la
mejor herencia que me pudiste dejar
porque el original
el verdadero eres tú donaldo barros
mi padre el que me enseñó del que heredé
del que sigo siendo y el que seguiré
tranquilo el resto de mi vida sabiendo
que llevo tu nombre con orgullo
con alegría con respeto con desparpajo
con irreverencia y sobre todo con
humildad lo hiciste bien
lo hiciste bien porque te ame
veamos llamaré
y te recuerdo todos los días de mi vida
y lo hacía aún cuando estabas en este
planeta en esta tierra siempre pensé en
ti pienso en ti y pensar en ti donaldo
garros donaldo barros
el dolor como te digo
como te diré simplemente gracias gracias
por ayudarme a entender la vida y
gracias por ayudarme y enseñarme a
entender la muerte
louis todavía en papá
existen muy bien
veamos